this could be this could be good news if
you're not a Facebook or Facebook it
seems to be crumbling that's right
research from Princeton University
compared adoption and abandonment
dynamics of social networks and they
compared that with dynamics that govern
the spread of infectious diseases and
basically that these things blow up
immediately like a disease it just blows
up immediately and spreads and that sort
of what happened with Facebook and then
suddenly it dies out very quickly so for
you graph people what you're seeing
there is that burst and that burst in
the middle that is check that out
shareholders yeah yeah exactly that's
not good if you're a shareholder right
there you're good if you're at about
twenty twelve right in the middle there
but that ultimately you much like a
virus which we get you know we can cure
often and deal with with medicine it
starts disappearing and that's what's
happening with Facebook as we speak
right now and they're saying that
Facebook is going to lose 80% of its
peak users between 2015 and 2017 I mean
that is basically tomorrow is this
surprising to you guys because I been
taught since we've been doing the show
we've been talking about the Facebook
fatigue thing check out my joke I did on
myspace this week first of all I love
the comparisons they give to like an
epidemic disease but I it's not
surprising to me because what's happened
with Facebook is that it's really just
become like a verbal diarrhea of
emotions and depressing states that
people are in it's like my cat died and
my you know whoa is the life that and
everybody's like scrolling through like
I don't want to see this it's also it's
becoming between that and like you know
hey mom look at all the illegal [ __ ] I'm
doing take this out so you can you know
yell at me later it's it's become this
this realm of just like you know
emotional outpouring and criticism from
parents and I think also in this
generation we need something faster and
that's why Instagram and Twitter it's
like I don't want to have to search for
things I want to just scroll down and
have my brain be you know and you've
completely ignored all the wonderful
shots of shrimp skewers I'm not gonna
eat it
yeah so this doesn't surprise you at all
then it's a phase I remember when they
thought rock and roll would be forever
you know the comedy boom stick around
long enough you just watch the trees
rise and drop in the backyard it's like
the time machine yeah so okay so clearly
the thing is gonna keep going now we
have Twitter and Instagram snapchat is
the new is the new hot one is that gonna
be the next thing so it's just gonna be
cyclical like that and we'll have three
year bursts with these things
yeah and but then what is that show for
the economics of it because you know
snapchat turned down three billion are
they gonna look look at that and go we
really screwed think it's gonna teach
them a lesson of what you need to get on
board in terms of what's your you know
the time for imbalance of when I need to
buy sell you know snapchat to me is a
very interesting thing and I personally
am terrified of it I don't know if you I
got on it this week and I have to say
I've seen I mean all people are doing is
sending me silly faces and I said
because you must have way more team
friends than maybe just wait yeah I'm
gonna get on it just nobody doesn't have
a camera yeah we're all citizen
reporters at all times but these things
you just they mostly tell us remember
don't shoot the world get your own face
dirt yeah that is training a it's like
instead of Big Brother it's self brother
I'll just monitor myself don't worry NSA
I got it
I'll watch me all day long yeah so you
hit on two things I want to get to there
so first off because of the NSA stuff is
that part of this also that there's now
this real distrust of technology and
finally we're finally realizing that we
shouldn't be putting all the stuff out
there in new iPhones already they just
hand you the thing and then you put your
fingerprint on it well we know they're
stealing everything else now they can
steal your fingerprints too we pay them
to take our information so it's part of
the reason that Facebook is fizzling out
is people are realized there's this
there's just like a fatigue of
information and there's a distrust now
finally which i think is actually kind
of healthy i mean i don't think that
we're that far
can't give us benefit of the doubt and
that one I mean I think that it's always
working in the back of your mind but
you've already given them the
information you know your email your
phone number your address your age sex
location whatever and and now I think
it's just that people are on to the next
one and so what's hot next you know
they're like over it do you guys think
it's also partly the personal thing that
you both talked about that it becomes
this just sort of personal Here I am
taking picture versus something like
Twitter which is more about information
which is why I like Twitter it's like
you're pushing out information versus
Facebook is about drivel mostly it's
your friends you know my new show of
their daily life so that what people
really want for social media is to
connect with people they don't know not
to connect with people they do know I
know I sound crazy Rick you gotta know I
it's gonna happen you're gonna connect
with those I think there is that desire
but I connect mostly with people I have
some basic knowledge of even if I
haven't met them personally we've
communicated enough I see where they're
coming from morally or whatever I have
lots of conservative friends on there
who we we may not agree politically but
when it comes stuff like Monsanto
instantly all right on the same line I'm
finding it I would never have dreamt of
this bridge occurring had I not had that
encounter with these people on Facebook
yeah I think I think honestly what's
really happening is that our attention
span is getting shorter and shorter and
Facebook has too much information like
you you don't have a 188 character limit
or things like that and it's like of 147
48 you know I I think that now it's like
we need Instagram where it's like I'm
just scrolling like pictures in your
mind is like oh here's this you know
molten lava cake and it's fun time at
the club last night and Twitter it's the
same thing it's like small blips of
information I think Facebook is becoming
a little too drawn out for the likes of
our attention span